hey everybody welcome back all right so
in this mini supplemental video what
we're going to be talking about is how
to compute the discrete Fourier
transform matrix okay so we should know
by now that in practice usually we're
gonna want to use the fast Fourier
transform command in MATLAB but in case
you're interested in how to actually
compute the discrete Fourier transform
matrix I thought this would be a nice a
little bit of code so let's go check out
the computer so here we have a copy of
the lecture notes and this is
essentially the matrix that we're trying
to compute so this matrix here will give
us the discrete Fourier transform so the
idea is you take in data at some points
0 through n minus 1 you multiply it by
this phat this discrete Fourier
transform matrix and you get your
frequency coefficients out okay and so
this Omega n is kind of the fundamental
sampling frequency okay so let's go see
if we can code this up in MATLAB so I'm
just gonna clear all close all and I
want to compute this for a vector of
input data that's length 500 okay so my
big n is going to be 500 I'm just gonna
create an X which is one's 500 by 1 and
I'm going to take the FFT y equals FFT
of X so this is how we would normally we
would normally use the fast Fourier
transform but today we're going to do
the discrete Fourier transform and
actually compute compute this matrix so
W equals e to the minus I times 2 pi
divided by big n so that's this W here
is this fundamental frequency and then
we're going to create a matrix of 1 1 1
1 1 Omega Omega squared dot 1 Omega
squared Omega fourth dot dot dot and so
on we're gonna compute this matrix okay
so I'm just going to show you two ways
of doing this
the slow and steady version is going to
use four loops so I'm going to say for I
equals 1 to N for J equals 1 to N I'm
going to say my DFT matrix at I and J is
equal to my W my fundamental frequency
to the I minus 1 times J minus 1 power
ok so you can go back to this formula
and you can convince yourself that this
matrix here the I J's elements of that
matrix is W to the I minus 1 times J
minus 1 okay so just check that out
yourself let me say and and and this
matrix DFT should give me the exact same
answer as my FFT ok so I'm just going to
create a plot figure the first thing I'm
going to plot is okay so my MATLAB
crashes whenever I try to do a fast
Fourier transform let's run this one
more time so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to plot the answer that FFT gives
me right that's going to give me a bunch
of numbers like 500 and I'm also going
to plot what I get when I take my data
times my DFT matrix okay and hopefully
they're exactly the same thing okay
let's go back to my code okay I'll just
do my slow and steady version
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to plot the real part of Y
so these are complex numbers I'm just
gonna plot the real parts I'm gonna plot
that in black dashed lines or maybe red
- red solid line black line okay
hold on and then I'm gonna plot the real
parts of my DFT matrix times X so DFT
times x should be exactly the same as
what my FFT gives me and I'm gonna plot
this in red dashes okay so I'm gonna run
the first part then the second part and
we see for the coefficients that matter
they're very very similar okay so what I
want to do now is I actually want to
plot this DFT matrix so this is kind of
a cool way of plotting this matrix this
big discrete Fourier transform matrix if
I plot the real part of all of the
coefficients notice that there's some
pretty neat patterns here if I make it
bigger you can see kind of all of these
neat patterns but there's an interesting
effect when I start to change the size
here notice that the number of cells
actually starts to change this is just
because of aliasing effects on the
screen I hope you can see this in the
online version but notice as I change
the the size of this the number of rolls
here actually becomes more and more and
more that's just an alias in effect but
it looks really cool so this is the
discrete Fourier transform matrix we can
visualize it like this there is a faster
way of computing this I'll say the
really fast way to compute instead of
using a for loop what we're going to do
is the following we're gonna compute
this mesh grid so instead of for I
equals one to n J equals 1 to N I'm
going to compute a 2d grid of all of my
IJ locations that's I J
equals mesh grid from 1 to N 1 to n ok
so these are now both two-dimensional
objects they're arrays and I'm going to
save my DFT matrix equals W dot dot to
the power big I minus 1 dot times big J
minus 1 ok so each of these big I and
big J matrices have you know all of my
IJ locations and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take for every single
element in that array I'm going to
multiply that I minus 1 times that J
minus 1 and I'm going to take W to that
power and I'm going to populate this
two-dimensional array and so when we do
this in MATLAB using these dot to the
power and dot times this uses really
really fast vectorized operations and
it's much faster than for loops okay and
if I just compute this thing I should be
able to get the exact same image okay so
this is the exact same image as if I use
the for loop okay so that's that's it
we're able to compute exactly this
discrete Fourier transform matrix we've
shown that it gives us exactly the same
answer as the fast Fourier transform and
we've also shown that if I used
vectorized operations like dot to the
power and dot times on these mesh grid
elements then it's much faster to
compute okay so that's all for now thank
you